foreign
[Music]
oh my company
how on Earth did you get in here oh
please don't fret I have no intention of
making a meal of you please call me the
Duke I'm but a humble Merchant for the
veil of goods to Lords and Ladies
prophets and priestesses
I do so strive to please my patrons I
hope we can become well acquainted but
of course it is not I who was on display
here but rather the Wares on offer for
you
I deal in all manner of Commerce but
today I trade in knowledge
this place is a veritable horde of
information
gathered from all throughout the Realms
of man
the more hard one the knowledge the
higher the price
but you look like you're well aware of
the value of such things
well since we're here I've got a few
morsels I'd love to share with such a
connoisseur please
take a gander
[Music]
happy half birthday Rose
I just want to find my daughter
[Music]
always be there for you no matter what
[Music]
You Are My Precious Rose
and I didn't care
so long as we were together
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Avatar
I love you but I won't let anything
happen to Rose
I've got this
[Music]
[Music]
I'm Kento kenoshita the director of the
Winter's expansion
gave his life to protect Rose and in the
end you see how she's grown
what kind of person is 16 year old Rose
that's what we wanted to explore so we
decided to have her at that age in this
expansion
said you had something important to tell
me
[Music]
she's trying to get rid of her unwanted
Powers but to do that she is forced to
return to the origin of her Misfortune
we thought that concept had a lot of
potential for an interesting story so
the setting this time is the realm of
Consciousness going back one more time
to that Village
the word nightmare is synonymous with
fear for instance if you've ever had a
childhood fever that caused a nightmare
even if they only last for an instant
like the feeling of being attacked by a
giant doll or something else similarly
so completely unrealistic can remain as
a fragment of a memory for the rest of
your life I wanted the core of the
feeling of fear to come from the kind of
memories and Nightmares that still haunt
people to this day
we wanted to choose characters that
would interest people who didn't play
The Mercenaries mode but would be
interested in playing a different type
of character
there are characters called Lords and
plain is them allows you to perform
amazing skills and attacks that a
regular human could not being able to
play them was more fun so that's why we
chose those characters
we balance things to ensure that as
little time as possible is spent waiting
for enemies to appear for instance if a
player doesn't finish off an enemy it
will chase after the player we made
adjustments like this to raise the tempo
and increase the fun of defeating enemy
after enemy
in an FPS you experience the game world
as if it's through your own eyes so it
can be incredibly scary to play a horror
game from that perspective
there are some players out there who
might find it too scary or experience
motion sickness in the first person
perspective they might not enjoy the FPS
genre
so we wanted to make a third person mode
for those players
to enjoy the game to its fullest
while there's still a sense of immersion
and fear with a third-person perspective
when the player character dies it
doesn't feel as much like you yourself
or die and you can enjoy playing it as a
game to confront the fear that it
creates which is a very different
experience I think third person mode is
a perfect way for people to return to
Resident Evil Villages as both a game
and an experience wouldn't it be okay to
show Ethan's face he gave that question
some thought
so even in third person mode if you try
to turn the camera to see his face Ethan
will look away and you're not quite able
to get a good look
each of the three editions are
interesting in their own way and we hope
you really enjoy the expansion please
look forward to it thank you
thank you
foreign
starting today a demo for the third
person mode will be available
here is the release date and platforms
for the demo
this demo can be played for a total of
60 minutes in third person mode or the
previously existing first person mode
Mission adjustment
no doesn't change anything
in a while since we fought together
Captain do
some fun people
move out
yes okay
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
verse is free content for those who own
Resident Evil Village or Resident Evil
Village Gold Edition
this game has cross play and you can
fight players across all platforms
those who already own Resident Evil
Village will be able to participate in
the Early Access period starting October
24th additionally updates are planned
for Resident Evil are reverse after it
has been officially released
here are some details for the Early
Access and updates
Resident Evil Village will be playable
on even more platforms
hello everyone my name is Jeremy sandmo
and I'm part of the GPU software team at
Apple during the keynote at our
worldwide developers conference Capcom
announced Resident Evil Village will be
coming to the Mac later this year and
will take full advantage of the power
and performance of Apple silicon we
couldn't be more excited that the game
will be available to Mac users around
the world beginning Friday October 28th
Resident Evil Village is the first
Project based on capcom's re engine to
support the mac and runs natively on
Apple silicon
and since the game is optimized to take
advantage of metal 3 features like metal
effects upscaling gameplay is incredibly
responsive with high frame rates and
beautiful visuals
this means that every Mac from MacBook
Air to Mac Studio will be able to play
Resident Evil village with ease stay
tuned for more information soon
hello everyone I am midoro from ubitus
and I am yonatani from ubitus it is a
great honor to be taking part in This
Global project of the Resident Evil
franchise on cloud with Capcom
with the launch of the cloud version not
only fans from Japan but from all over
the world can play the game on
Nintendo's switch without thinking about
the download time
the application size is small but the
users can experience smooth gameplay of
up to 60 FPS while playing it in
multiple modes that Nintendo switch
offers such as TV mode tabletop mode and
handheld mode it is great to be able to
focus on the gameplay without thinking
about storage space or the download time
you can also check your network
environment by playing the demo before
you pre-order or purchase the game
the game can be pre-ordered or purchased
after you play the demo this is to make
sure that those who are playing a cloud
game for the first time or may have
concerns can test it and enjoy the game
with 5G mobile network technology being
so widespread recently the barrier
between installing the game and playing
it on cloud is getting smaller and
smaller we hope you will enjoy it and
Marvel at the technology of cloud gaming
as well as its future through the
release of Resident Evil Village cloud
Resident Evil Village Cloud will be
available on October 28th in the
Winter's expansion DLC will follow on
December 2nd
furthermore re2 Cloud will launch on
November 11th followed by the re3 cloud
on November 18th and re7 Cloud will be
available on December 16th
foreign
how delightful
such delectable information are to be
savored what's that you want more
what a greedy thing you are no it's
quite all right I love to see a healthy
appetite I'll do my best to Sage your
hunger come have a look at this
thank you
hello everyone
I'm the producer of Resident Evil 4.
yoshiaki hirabayashi I'm here today to
deliver the newest information about the
title
first please enjoy this new gameplay
footage
how far can you have gone
[Applause]
foreign
home
[Music]
hey
I read you
what's your situation
the hell is going on
what was that
the [ __ ] way
foreign
this is Condor one hunnigan here what's
your sit rep
our Intel is correct then well done
something's happened to the people here
my escorts are
gonna go talk later
come on
kill me for the repairs later
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
what did you think
as you just saw
we are paying respect to the original
game's World while implementing new
ideas and stated they are Graphics to
strengthen the Core Concepts of the
title
we think this game will provide a fresh
experience with a sense of familiarity
if you play the original that both
newcomers and Veterans to Resident Evil
4 will enjoy
the [ __ ] way the gennados will have
all new ways to attack they are closing
in on Leon during his mission and will
attack with an even greater variety of
methods than in the original release
Leon fights back with Firearms close
combat Maneuvers a newly added Perry
using his nut and more
[Applause]
resource management and upgrade elements
are critical for survival
just as in the original using the
attache case effectively will be key in
addition to managing the weapons and
items you carry and synthesizing herbs
this also allows you to craft ammunition
and other items
stranger of course we can't forget the
merchant
you can purchase weapons and items and
customize them to suit your playstyle
we've also added a trade mechanic where
rare gems you've collected can be
exchanged for special items
we are rebuilding the original game
while respecting its core experience
adding new ideas and modernizing the
play field
now I'd like to share some new
information regarding this product's
release
we announced that Resident Evil 4 will
also be available on Playstation 4. in
addition to PlayStation 5 Xbox series X
and Xbox series s and PC
the PlayStation 4 version can be
upgraded to the PlayStation 5 digital
version at no additional cost
I'd like to introduce two other
additions we are preparing for players
looking for more than the standard
edition
foreign
the first is the deluxe edition which
will be available for all platforms
this includes additional content such as
costumes special weapons a treasure map
and more
next is the physical only collector's
edition
this Edition includes the contents of
the deluxe edition as well as a leon
figure a special map art book soundtrack
and more
also pre-orders start today
if you pre-order the standard edition
you'll receive the attache case gold and
special charm handgun ammo foreign
if you pre-order the deluxe edition or
collector's edition you'll receive the
standard edition pre-order bonuses as
well as attache case classic and special
charm green herb
if you pre-order the digital version on
the PlayStation Store you'll receive a
mini soundtrack
you can secure these bonuses by
pre-ordering Resident Evil 4.
thank you for watching so far we are
working hard to create a game that
everyone will enjoy
so please look forward to it before I go
we have one more update for you let's
take a look
[Music]
foreign
you're here looking for someone
maybe some missing senorita
Ashley
where are you
your soul requires
cleansing
Ashley Graham are you in here
just let me go listen
here in the president's orders
what is that
dude a lot of Slams are escaping we need
to go
I'm gonna get
you can stop right there
Ada
who are you what are you doing here
Ashley run
the entire world
now
abandon your body leave the girl
she's lost no matter what
now that he has chosened death
[Music]
oh you gotta be kidding me
foreign
did you enjoy the Resident Evil showcase
let's recap
first Resident Evil Village Gold Edition
Launches on Friday October 28th if you
already own Resident Evil Village you
could purchase the Winter's expansion
DLC separately the Winter's expansion
includes three additional modes
third person mode so you can enjoy the
main game in A New Perspective the
powered up the mercenaries additional
orders and the new story campaign
Shadows of rose
oh yes a demo for the third person mode
will be available today
don't forget
The Early Access period for Resident
Evil are in verse begins October 24th
for all owners of Village Resident Evil
Village Cloud playable on Nintendo
switch via a cloud service will be
available starting October 28th Resident
Evil 2 Resident Evil 3 and Resident Evil
7 are also coming to Nintendo switch via
Cloud at a later date
also the Mac version of Resident Evil
Village will be released on October 28th
the newest entry in the series Resident
Evil 4 will release on Friday March 24th
2023 and you can pre-order it today
we hope you look forward to it
thank you very much for watching
well well looks like you've had your
filled
such a grand display I should hope so oh
I'm afraid I have an appointment I must
attend to just a bit of bartering with
another Merchant
an odd chap but his information is good
and I shouldn't say anymore
anyway I do hope I'll see you again I'll
strive to prepare a suitably satisfying
stock of goods